they're a familiar sight for
holidaymakers in Greece the colorful
kyuh kyuh fishing boats but the
traditional wooden boats are an
increasingly rare sight the European
Union pays fishermen cash if they scrap
their kiya kiya Dimitri's maracas is the
last boat builder on the island of Chios
now he has to destroy the boats that he
built over the past decades otherwise
the fishermen won't get their subsidy
Baracus is appalled I think about all
the energy I put into them and when it's
meant to me over the years now I'm
supposed to destroy all this I'm sad
breaks my heart a little okay but the
real problem is is that it puts the
fishermen in this terrible situation our
donors Castanias owns a fish restaurant
he also gave up his boat last year taxes
for it kept rising and his catch
dwindled it was a difficult decision but
at least he got a hundred thousand euros
for the boat now he has to buy his fish
for his restaurant elsewhere and he
still misses his boat only problem is
that it was tough I didn't want to
destroy my boat I'd even have paid money
to keep it for myself or use it to ferry
tourists but the Agriculture Ministry
wouldn't agree to it no chance the UN
calls the Mediterranean the world's most
overfished see though the kiyow kiyow
are hardly to blame the Greek government
would like the votes to be used to ferry
tourists but that's not financially
viable for the fishermen
image there my national we want to save
the traditional wooden boats Goffe but
to do that the EU has to change the
guidelines there's a lot less money to
use them for tourism but the financial
incentives should be the same as for
scrapping Bernalillo Terra Amata
O'Donnell artists create a museum
dedicated to the Kea Kea is being built
on the island of samos the Greek
Ministry of Culture has rescued twenty
old boats all lovingly made by hand
Costas communities as an architect and
an expert on Greek shipbuilding
traditions
he's fighting to preserve the old boats
more and more people including
government officials now say they should
be protected as an endangered cultural
heritage you have to keep things from
the past and to to save memories to save
our roots there is the traditional boat
building which is a very integral part
of this of this culture and we have to
find ways to keep them and to to give a
future to make them alive for the future
for the young people Dimitri's maracas
also gives boat building classes for
young people and adults he'd like to be
able to take on an apprentice maracas
can't accept that Greece's maritime
heritage is on the verge of extinction
as a stopgap measure he's figured out a
loophole instead of completely scrapping
the boats he takes them apart to render
them unusable
Applebee malleus remain i disassembled
the boats in three parts which are still
in time a good boat builder could put
them back together maybe some young
people will come along and want them who
knows as long as ke Kia continued to be
scrapped the craft will die out
that's why Greek boat builders and
fishermen are calling on their
government to reopen negotiations with
the EU even if the kiyow kiyow can no
longer ply the seas they could at least
be preserved as a tourist attraction